samsung won't stop we have the brand new
galaxy buds 2 pro and we are going to
see how do they compare to apple's
airpods pro the previous ones were
remarkably good and these ones should be
a lot better they increased the price to
230 bucks but that compares to 250 on
the earpods of course through amazon you
can buy them for 180 bucks now and with
these you'll also be able to get a
discount soon so we'll leave the links
down in the video description let's get
this bad boy opened up and not only are
we gonna compare the design the
convenience the sound quality active
noise cancellation but also the ambient
mode which has lacked in the past
samsung said that they made these 15
smaller now the case seems similar but
these definitely are small with that the
airpods still seem smaller but of course
it's a completely different design and i
can't wait to see how flush this is in
my ear which is a downside with the
airpods now as far as the cases
apples definitely still has them beat
because of how thin it is it's less
noticeable in the pocket samsung's is
smaller overall but it is a little bit
more bulky or noticeable as far as
battery life samsung has apple beat in
every single way including now with
faster charging in 5 minutes and with
that the same thing goes for
waterproofing these things are now ipx7
rated meaning you could submerge them in
three feet of water for up to 30 minutes
which is crazy compared to the airpods
with ipx4 meaning they're just sweat and
maybe rain resistant i gotta be honest
these air pods are getting old i can't
believe apple hasn't updated them yet
hopefully they will soon because these
galaxy buds 2 pro
these things actually have bluetooth 5.3
and they support 24-bit
lossless sound when connected to a
samsung phone that's new that's why i
have this s22 ultra ready enough with
the talking let's go ahead and pop these
into my ear
all right
they feel very very lightweight i don't
know about what the weight officially is
and how much they lowered it they don't
really stick out too far i think they
made it stick out less than before of
course the air pods have those stems
that do stick all the way down these
things also have a pressure release vent
so when i put it in it releases the
pressure to get rid of that plugged
feeling and it does work really well
apple brought that out and kind of
innovated with the airpods and that was
a big selling feature so now let me go
ahead and pull one of these out pop one
of these in and let's compare the
comfort i gotta be honest the air pods
do feel better because the only part
that really makes pressure is a little
rubber seal that goes into your ear and
that's super soft whereas with the
galaxy buds 2 pro i do feel the whole
casing in my ear touching my ear and now
let's test out the active noise
cancellation samsung says that it's 40
percent better so i want to hear it i
went ahead and connected it made sure
the software is on the latest version
and swapped out the ear tips for the
best fit let me start out with the air
pods since i've used these a ton
alright active noise cancellation kicks
in that that sound is almost all the way
gone a little bit of highs left over but
even go ahead and say something hey man
how's it going good it's going good
you have
you still have some highs in your voice
but a lot of the low end went away even
my voice yeah all right let's take these
out let's pop in the galaxy buds 2 pro
moment of truth let's hit the active
noise cancellation button
all right that was quick switching over
yeah i mean go ahead and say something
hey man how's it going
good are you talking any louder than you
did before same thing i think yeah same
all right
well i have a proper seal
that vent above us i hear more of the
high end
it seems like maybe a little bit more of
my low end of my voice went away and
even vadim talking but i still hear you
louder
than i did with the airpods let's try
these ones again
vadim say something hey
it's yeah that is what i'm hearing now
to my ears
uh yes i hear more of the low end with
these
but the samsung's you get more of the
high-end sound and volume in general
still sounds a little bit louder which
is interesting now let's compare the
ambient sound or transparency mode in
what better way than with our new
feature voice detect so if you have this
enabled as soon as i start talking it
should switch over which it did vadim go
ahead and say something hey
so
you're tired of saying hey
you sound pretty natural your voice
doesn't sound high in any way do i sound
like a robot no you sound excellent now
the weird thing is that annoying vent
once again
it sounds louder than in real life
and
a little bit higher pitch
and my voice
also that low end is kind of uh not
there as much as we have in real life
but in general that is surprising um
they've definitely improved this and i
want to test out the microphone as well
and now time for the kings in this area
i wish i had the auto mode to switch but
i switched it myself with the controls
uh but em say something do i sound
natural this time
yes uh you sounded natural before too
but you sound
extremely close to normal let me go
ahead and switch this again honestly
these cannot be beat i put it in the
transparency mode kicks in and then
everything sounds just like it did or
extremely close to when i had nothing at
all these things cannot be beat in that
area and now let's compare the
microphones this is the microphone
quality of apple's airpods pro in a
normal room that does have some ac noise
and this is the microphone of samsung's
galaxy buds 2 pro in the same kind of
room go ahead and let me know down in
the comments section which one sounds
better to you and now let's finally get
to the sound quality which is where i
have really high expectations for the
galaxy buds 2 pro
i have a few different songs we're going
to listen you guys can hear the songs
from myself so then after when i
described what i heard you guys know
what i'm talking about and let's start
out with the earpods and this first song
which is a mix of kind of
pop electronics
[Music]
all right guys well
if you love bass
these things deliver and they won't shut
off because they're touch sensitive
instead of the stems
um the highs were a little bit too crisp
for me and of course we can go into the
app and then we can swap that so i'm
going to go ahead and tone that down
just a bit but for music like this where
that bass really helps uh these things
definitely sound better than the airpods
pro the previous ones did as well
they've updated and made it better and
they do a great job this next one is a
modern take on a classical song
with a lot of different changes
some headphones or earbuds will kind of
distort in a certain area so let's go
ahead and take a listen
[Music]
all right guys
these things
after that tweak sounded fantastic
first thing
these are like subwoofers in your ears i
mean they have like the dual driver kind
of set up and they're the two-way
drivers uh a ton of bass some of you
guys are going to want to turn that down
uh with that um when there's a little
sweep kind of across both ears over the
stereo the air pods they do have like a
wider
kind of sound stage compared to um the
samsung's but with that there's one part
where there's a lot of stuff changing
and it actually sounded better and
cleaner on these galaxy buds so i'm
thoroughly impressed
uh volume is great vadim how is the how
does the sound leakage compare you're
sitting over there like eight feet away
uh so for the airpods pro i could barely
hear them barely hearing and then i
could hear just a little bit of the
instruments like that uh snare whatever
that is
but with the galaxy buds i could
basically hear the entire song
everything everything
well these vents are huge and they work
and these are loud but if you don't want
people hearing your music the airpods
are a lot better for that uh yeah these
things vadeem you're hearing everything
well now let's switch to our last song
and for the last song we have this rock
track which has so many different
instruments and layers makes it quite
difficult and really makes
good headphones and earbuds stand out
from bad ones so let's go ahead and jump
in
[Music]
[Music]
wow
okay well that's why i say that that is
a hard test because let me tell you at
first both of them sound good but we
have those vocals in the beginning but
as soon as everything drops and you have
all those instruments the difference is
substantial the air pods with a single
driver that's been out for a while it
just gets muddy all that kind of mixes
together the vocals the instruments the
like uh synthesizer kind of in the
background whereas here not only do you
have a lot more bass that it's not only
the amount of bass but it's very full
the vocals still stand good the the
synthesizer
the drums the guitars you hear all those
different layers and it is much much
nicer to listen to
than the airpods so as far as audio
quality
definitely the samsungs have the win
uh if you care about music and the sound
quality these things these things are
notch and i really hope that apple
updates these and makes them dual
drivers so they can do a good job as
well they definitely need to
so overall which one is better well i
like that the air pods seal everything
in there's not much sound leakage that
is definitely probably my biggest
disappointment uh with the galaxy buds
but overall samsung has done such a
killer job updating these making them
better adding uh the pressure vents
making them smaller and lighter they're
they're killing it they're absolutely
killing it so if you care about uh the
sound quality and some of the other
features you cannot go wrong with these
and as far as the airpods pro i mean at
this time i would probably say
wait if you can for an update because
these things they definitely need it so
there you guys go you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below we have links to both
click that circle above to subscribe and
check out one of those great videos
right over there it's been max with max
tech and i will see you in the next
video
[Music]